[Music]
well it is indeed a pleasure to welcome
my old friend bill crouch our and to
introduce him to you today to many of
you of course he needs no introduction
at all bill was a student of chem Gryson
at Cornell and Ken gryson in turn was a
stew is was Bruno's first American
student bill joined the MIT faculty in
1949 and worked first with the
synchrotron and then in in the air
shower research that went on for a
number of years and as I remarked in
1958 he initiated the project that
discovered cosmic gamma rays and in fact
laid the foundation for one of the main
scientific efforts of the United States
and the European space program in the
mid 60s he moved to the University of
Wisconsin where he built the premier
x-ray group that has pioneered the
exploration of the soft x-ray sky and I
remember the day when we were bought
we're walking back from the fnt diner I
think we were crossing the railroad
tracks or hazy memory of tracks and bill
said how about doing a gamma-ray
experiment on a satellite well bill went
ahead and submitted a 300-pound proposal
to the powers that be in Washington
which preceded the formation of of NASA
a 300-pound proposal a query came back
from Washington can you do it for a
hundred pounds sure and and now we're
going to hear Bill Crouch our tell us
that story
my George has a remarkably a generous
way about him I'm always a little
embarrassed when George sorry
louder I thank you George is all I meant
to say a George's explained about the
air shower experiment at the Agatha's
station of the Harvard College
Observatory it I ran for a couple of
years and there was no convincing
evidence of any preferred direction of
arrival the number of events was
extremely small so the next step was
designed and build another experiment
with a much larger area which you heard
about having slogged about in the snow
and mud and the mosquito environment for
about two years most of us were tired of
that ready for physics in a more
traditional environment a tabletop for
example a one personally redeeming
feature of the physical awkwardness of
the air shower experiment was the extra
time I got to spend with my kids the
apparatus was located there in the
Harvard College Observatory which is in
Harvard Massachusetts I lived in Concord
and the experiment needed adjustments
and so forth quite frequently so every
Sunday morning I would go out with my
kids and I'd make adjustments on the
apparatus while my kids fixed-fixed
cocoa and drank it it was a it was a
happy time about this time the
possibility of detecting gamma rays from
celestial sources would be was being
discussed by a few people among the my
colleagues and Phil Morrison who at that
time was at Cornell the upper limits of
a possible gamma ray component
the cosmic radiation had been set in the
40s and early 50s by among others Bob
full sizer and Bruno Rossi they sent my
energy the used ionization chambers were
carried aloft by a cluster of weather
balloons launched from the Lincoln lab
building out in Lexington Massachusetts
and the idea was the search for gamma
ray component of cosmic rays by stood by
the searching for good the shower
production and a few radiation lengths
of lead the balloons were made of thin
rubber which had to be boiled in water
for most of the night in preparation for
an early morning launch I don't remember
why you had to boil in the water but you
did the work established a new upper
limit of the gamma-ray intensity above
four and a half B II V and I believe it
led to Bob hull cisors a PhD thesis but
why look for gamma rays well I had a
number of reasons one of them was a
simplistic notion that it's always a
good idea to look in new domains of
wavelengths a sensitivity and whatnot I
know there was a desperate feeling that
there ought to be some kind of anti
sokrati associated with cosmic rays
either with their production or with
their interactions surely cosmic ray
protons and their interactions with
interstellar gas ought to produce
neutral pie mesons and the DK gamma rays
if detected would reveal the site of
these collisions that this was
particularly emphasized by Morrison the
other reason was to follow up on a
possible embarrassment for the then
trendy study state cosmology recall the
idea the large scale features of the
universe were supposed to appear the
same to all observers in both space and
time
since the universe is expanding it
followed that to keep the moon
the matter density about constant the
new matter had a new matter had to be
created and if has looked reasonable the
new matter was both matter and
antimatter the antiprotons grease that
created at least in our galaxy ought to
annihilate and produce gamma rays in the
region 50 or 60 or 70 MeV the
availability of scintillation detectors
made it possible to design the fastly
improved balloon borne gamma ray
instruments and together with Tom Klein
who is a skilled and very very hard
working graduate student the development
of a balloon bore an instrument was
started and in July of 1960 he was ready
to fly I could I have the first view
graph please that this is the kalam
balloon borne apparatus is a reporter
oh thank you
the gamma rays were supposed to come in
through the lead kilometer I go through
an anti coincidence things which were
food which would reject charge particles
go into a a para converter and I get
detected here in the I turned off
counter at the upper layer of mercury
was to provide a cross-section
measurement because the mercury could be
moved in and out and that we hope would
convince us as well as others that was
that gamma rays were really being
detected
a3 salts which are on the next slide
we're convincing that we were looking at
gamma rays at the top of the atmosphere
the intensity was very small
and then the end the intensity increased
as you came down and heights and
eventually got to be very small back at
sea level this is a blow up but just at
the data
near the top of the atmosphere and an
extrapolation of this goes through zero
by the way the fact that the
that so many gamma rays are produced in
the Earth's atmosphere precludes the use
of balloons to look at the collision
gamma rays from outer space because
looking across the whole galaxy the
thickness is only a few milligrams per
square centimeter and the book the best
balloon technology gets you up to a few
thousand milligrams per square
centimeter so that the the background
problem is severe from balloons the
extrapolated extrapolated intensity at
the top of the atmosphere was very small
here but it was a back about a factor of
10 smaller than that predicted by the
study state a cosmology at the study
state enthusiasts had a lot of room to
maneuver however and I don't I think we
embarrassed them very much it was a
discovery of a three degree raging
radiation in 1965 of course that
provided the fatal embarrassment well it
was during these years that the Russians
launched Sputnik and provided a swift
kick to the US satellite effort
the details of exactly what happened
next are kind of fuzzy and by mine and I
look for the correspondence and I don't
seem to have very much of it I hadn't
any of it I guess it got lost in the
move to Wisconsin but we were asked to
submit a proposal and we guessed at the
amount of money that was required and
how long it would take and everything
was naive about our guesses the weight
but at the cost and how long it would
take all so they allowed us half a watt
which didn't seem very generous given
given the things we had to do well
the detector as it flew as Explorer 11
is shown on the next slide
that's a schematic a schematic of it the
gamma rays came in through the top and
got converted here and a converter and
then detected by a Cherenkov counter and
the whole thing was surrounded by a veto
veto counter or anti coincidence counter
what the thing actually looked like is
on the next slide
that's the detector we made three of
them I think this is the one that
actually flew one of the things we had
to do was to get the thing through a
vibration test and this was perfectly
awful photomultipliers were not designed
at that time to fly on apparatus going
up on by going up on rackets I recall
quite vividly the the first vibration
test a late one night in Huntsville
after the test George Clark and I took
this piece of apparatus held it held it
like a baby and took it back to the
laboratory which was in a trailer and
the thing was dripping broken glass all
the way back we laid it out and looked
at it and looked at the extent of the
damage and I remember telling I remember
asking George well what do we do now
George is quite untypical remarked let's
pull up a blanket and make a run for it
I think there was a culture shock for
both both us and the Huntsville people
I'll never forget the look of disbelief
on their faces when I made some kind of
a minor adjustment with a Swiss Army
knife that was not their way well
shortly after that the
now flight into orbit was planned and
mostly because of our inexperience in
dealing with a hard-nosed engineers and
rocket scientists that are called a day
of the orbit that we got was a very very
poor but we spent six months in orbit
and we only got nine hours of data but
the reason for that was we went up very
high into the radiation bills and spent
most of right time up there where the
background was just enormous so
altogether we only had as I said nine
hours of data on the next
slide oh that's the thing as it went
into orbit this is the last stage of the
rocket which stayed with it and can I
have the next one please
I've got ahead of myself well
forward at the time of launch it spun
around a longitudinal axis about five
revolutions per second and then in a
matter of a couple of weeks the thing
began to process and it eventually ended
up spinning about a transverse axis but
the look Direction was out this way and
then as it processed around the sky we
got a look at a large number of
different directions
including the earth which is certain
which is on the next slide please
this is the cosine of the angle away
from the earth and this was the horizon
and this is the earth that we would be
looking at the intensity coming directly
from the earth was very large because
cosmic rays coming down which hit the
Earth's atmosphere and produce PIME
essence which decayed into gammas which
came back up out of thee out of the
atmosphere and the region over here was
what we were getting from the sky well
the statistics are clearly very very
modest we did not have a convincing
demonstration I don't think that we were
detecting gamma rays but a couple of
years later we were given the
opportunity to prepare an instrument for
the third a third orbiting solar
observatory oh so three that's on the
next slide
the main improvements were this where
the inclusion of a kind of a calorimeter
in here where we could measure the
energy of gamma rays although quite
poorly and the fact that the orbit of
this was much much more to our liking on
the next slide is the results again and
this would be towards the earth and this
would be towards the horizon and this is
looking out into the atmosphere at sky
and it was a more convincing case that
we were detecting gamma rays out here at
a level which was which was reasonable
on the next slide has shown the the
distribution with Galactic latitude this
is the Galactic plane and this would be
the North Galactic polar was me the
South Galactic Pole
and there clearly is a high intensity
towards the Galactic plane here here
here here and so forth I'm sorry I said
that wrong this is the Galactic a plane
going back and forth this way and these
are the poles yes I was right
the
a problem with these measurements in
general was that the angular resolution
was so extraordinarily poor the reason
for that is that you have to convert the
gamma rays into electron positron pairs
and this requires a converter but the
converter is very effective in
scattering the electrons so we were
limited to do something like a 15 or 20
degrees for the angular resolution of
the device things that occurred later
than this were usually done with spark
chambers and one of those is shown
schematically on the next slide this is
the this is a device which is called a
Cosby which we prepared by the Europeans
and as you see it contains a spark
chamber up here with a whole bunch of
thin plates and just let the camera get
detected in one of the place and then
you'd get a look at the electrons that
were produced before before there'd be a
lot of scattering on the next view graph
is shown the distribution about the
Galactic plane from Cosby from SAS -
which was a NASA thing and on the next
one is from Cosby is a map of the
Galactic plane which goes through here
and the intensity gets a smaller and
smaller and smaller as you go up towards
higher galactic latitudes and there's an
enormous amount of detail and not all of
it is significant but a lot of it is and
it indicates directions by and large in
which there's a concentration of gas
such as molecular clouds of the gamma
rays can be used as a probe of
concentrations of gas I'd like to add a
couple of things here
Bruno Rossi Jerrold Zacharias Peter
Dimas Fred Epling and her bridge all
supplied an enormous amount of logistic
and administrative support for the
efforts that George has talked about and
these and they are the fact that we
didn't have to go after funds it didn't
I didn't have to
the right proposal for our day-to-day
activity was a tremendous a tremendous
advantage that I think we all thoroughly
appreciate in addition to that kind of
support was the support of the technical
people the side turtle uh Bill Smith at
Mannion are all people who were
tremendously devoted and added an awful
lot to the to the possibility of success
in these things none of the three of us
Clark
hurgh are my army have pursued gamma-ray
astronomy beyond oh so three speaking
from me alone there was a number of
reasons but too much travel the too many
meetings too long between experiments
too hard to provide students with
hands-on or a tabletop experiencing
experimental physics these later things
were done by large groups both at NASA
at Europeans and most recently the gamma
ray Observatory my last slide is of a
Chi ro
and I guess my only comment about it is
things can get very complicated if you
don't watch out it's a it's not a
tabletop thing and I don't see how you
fit graduate students into it very
gracefully well
thank you all and thank you for
listening
[Applause]